[Music]
probably the next big game coming out
which a lot of people excited for is
persona 5 which a few people at the
GameSpot office have had for a while now
and have been even beaten it co people
in the UK cool yeah tomorrow saying Lucy
James over in the UK I've played a lot
of persona 5 and myself and I think I
think all three of you or persona fans
am I correct I'm I tend to like the Shin
Megami Tensei series a little bit more
okay when a plate of this one I like it
more than other persona games cool I do
have a few like Twitter questions about
persona but before we get into those as
someone who doesn't know anything about
the series I we went to lunch the other
day and I was asking you what's the even
the premise of this franchise sounds
kind of like from what you told me about
the mechanics in the structure it sounds
like something I would actually be into
based on the other RPGs similar to that
that I do like but as a newcomer to the
series I wanted to know from what you've
played and from a you guys understand of
it will it be a good introduction to
this series for me yeah I mean right off
the bat you don't need to know anything
about the previous games right like
there's no cares like yeah it's it's
brand new cast new set I mean they're
always kind of set in Japan but this is
like you know Shibuya this is like you
know the heart of Tokyo and it feels
like a much more modernized version of
what you know personas been doing up
until this point cuz like persona 4
golden was a big hit on Vita but it was
also a port of a PlayStation 2 game so
the last thing that we've seen from
persona is quite old at this point so
this game definitely looks like
something that you would expect today it
so it is cross-platform with ps3 and
there are some moments where you're kind
of like oh yeah I guess maybe the game
looks like it could have been better but
maybe it was held back a little bit but
by and large I think it's the style that
really kind of gives it its edge you
know where maybe the graphics aren't
like super impressive on a technical
level yeah for someone I'm familiar with
the series what's like the main allure
of it would you say I mean it sounds
like it's pretty multifaceted but yeah I
mean like the the primary thing is that
you sort of hop between this sort of
like slice of life day-to-day thing as a
student in high school and then you kind
of dip into this like dark like
alternate dimension where you have
control over magical powers and sort of
like an alternate personality
that is like a projection of like your
inner-self and they are the persona
I guess you compare them to stands from
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure maybe this is
the first one - that has it doesn't have
procedurally generated dungeons right
like the dungeons are actually from what
I've seen so far they seem to be set in
stone
were they procedurally generated before
and persona 4 they were okay cuz I
didn't get too far into that because I
actually like the day-to-day oh really
that was my favorite part of that gasps
a lot of people love I love slice of
life all about slice of life yeah that's
my jam I think it's just persona for
felt like it got to a kind of a slow
start or like a rolling start like a
really slow roll this one I kind of like
it because you're basically shipped off
from your hometown because god that's
because you you stop the crime from
happening but the police are sort of
like looking at you as someone who
intervened when they shouldn't have and
therefore you've been kicked out of your
school
so you're shipped off to live with this
guy who runs like a little restaurant
and yes he kind of like doesn't really
like you even though he volunteered to
take you in he's really unsure about you
and he's constantly giving all these
warnings like look man you're on your
last straw like you screw up you're out
of here and so you kind of feel like at
odds with everything but then you feel
like almost at home when you go go into
that the alternate dimension as it were
where things become a little bit less
tied down your character more about the
people around you and what they think of
themselves
sounds like high school yes I think
somebody mentioned in the chat a while
back but my good friend Andrew Goldfarb
over at IGN beat the game in Japanese so
if that's any indication of whether you
can approach this game as a newcomer he
does not speak Japanese at all so he was
just able to get through it so that kind
of says a lot to me about the
accessibility wasn't enjoyable the
biggest persona fan probably in the
entire world like this game definitely
maguet stylish and like you know the
menus look great and stuff like that and
some of the character avatars but
there's a huge variety of monsters in
this game and
some of them are throw backs to the past
but they're just like really strange
concoctions so like pretty much
everything you're looking at at all
times is like kind of intriguing in one
way or another so I think even if you
don't know Japanese the the combat
mechanics mixed with the design of the
world and the enemies is probably enough
to keep you going I would worry about
getting lost and not knowing where to go
me too
I mean I'm sure he consulted people cuz
I know a couple people who played in
Japanese and different different levels
of Japanese knowledge so he probably
asked people for help too but he think
he's trying to Platinum it in Japanese
and in English because that's just how
andrew is I love you Andrew the other
thing I like about persona is just
getting to pick your best girl who is
your persona for best girl I'm not that
deep Enya I've only played about five
hours or so I'm just getting started at
school I'm just sort of like people are
starting to get to know me as the weird
kid the out-of-town air that kind of
thing
sounds like a historical drama let's
make it funny you know me I know I'm
just kidding I was a weird kid still am
I want to know who makes best girl would
be that's why I want you only game I
want you to vote for son of five so you
can tell me who your best girl well let
me ask you who you think my best girl
would be I think that I saw a girl in a
cat suit that one we know I'm not on
board right now but explain what's with
her personality
I don't know she's like morning she's
she's presented early on as a very
interesting character who's kind of like
a pivotal character as you're learning
to cope with your powers and understand
like the situation's you're thrust into
because essentially like you just have
this cellphone and you're walking around
this new part of Tokyo to you and this
icon keeps appearing you're like go wait
get out of here but it persists and
that's the sort of thing that triggers
you going to another world and she's
involved as something in the real world
which then dictates sort of the behavior
of everything in that alternate
dimension okay it's very it's very
interesting like how quickly this game
presents a conflict to you that's that's
really like oh [ __ ] like that's a thing
in this game like and then they just
roll with it I don't want to spoil it
it's not like a huge deal but it
certainly sets an interesting tone early
on okay well I'm into the cat girl right
now
Jake what is your do you like a have you
played any other ones besides for no
just for summer for gold and it seems
like the one that correct me if I'm
wrong kind of justified everyone's view
to purchase that also seems to be the
most pervasive persona game or at least
maybe in the west or a my wrong oh
that's tough to say I mean three and
four both had a huge following like in
Japan it led to anime series and movies
and stuff like that and we've even I
guess three well at least four had its
own dancing and fighting games made
mm-hmm dancing game was kind of right
yeah but that was really good made by
Arc System Works that game was actually
great for a spin-off title but yeah in
the West I don't I think four was really
the first time that it kind of caught
mainstream attention so you can during
the combat your party will consist of
all personae or well so you have your
own abilities and weapons but then you
can call upon your personas to does that
not I don't know I was just countering
you I call upon your personas to do
certain things for you okay and you can
also negotiate with the demons that
you're fighting it's another kind of
core mechanic that came from the Shin
Megami Tensei series which this was born
from it's a persona seems to have the
spotlight now but she Megami Tensei was
the first okay cool I mean everything
I'm seeing looks like something I've
been getting into like an RPG I mean
I've always liked RPGs but I've been
getting into more RPGs lately and I
think the last one I really grinded with
was uh what was the I've reviewed it and
it's escaping me right now there's a
second bravely second thank you so much
and I liked it yeah and I think there
was a last one I really put time is just
grinding through and getting every class
for the characters right every job sorry
they're called making getting the pirate
the cowboy that just like everything you
can imagine honestly and I really like
the variety of that game which usually
seems like a cop-out but like a
hairdresser class
you said everything I could think of is
what the barista class just like that
was my main thing
now jigs he played five yet at all
persona five not bravely fifth no I I'm
looking forward to it yeah
this might this this seems like the game
that I want to like make myself get into
because I the RPG I wanted to dive into
as Mass Effect Andromeda and for those
are showing we haven't gotten to that
yet we will be talking about it but I do
have a few questions about personal 5
for people here on the lobby cast first
from our friend goop shoe riot a
frequenter of the lobby chats and
streams here at GameSpot there any word
on New Game+ yet I don't know about that
okay and it might be something we can't
even talk about if we did know yeah I
don't know he is a multi-tiered question
how do you have an idea of how many
characters there will be throughout the
playthrough I don't know how many have
you encountered so far in your time of
the game Kali or Pete I've encountered
two characters that are like in your
party okay beyond the main character yes
am i sorry three actually oh three like
a spoiler no I'm forgetful oh okay
and then also he yeah goo best who is
Bay whatever her name is she's perfect
and I love her the cat lady cat lady
sorry you just say she would be my no I
think she's perfect but I ok persona for
reese a all the way I don't mess with
Chie don't do that explain both of these
people to me
I don't remember personal cuz do that
much but I'm pretty sure he'd say was my
husband
looks like somebody the chat was just
mentioning before on the persona 5 art
direction and just like the overall art
direction of the series but for some
five specifically looks pretty cool
they're all it's definitely matured if
it's like I think three and four kind of
followed a very similar path this one
definitely is embracing like jazz eNOS I
don't take anything you're saying
jazzy a jazzy like comic-book style
which sounds right up one of my aliens
yeah it's very very stylish yeah and you
have one more question a little more
Floyd Chris
question ice I didn't write this Lloyd
Christmas John Twitter tweet sent me
every once in a while I really like that
name that's his real name that's awesome
but probably not you know him from boy
Christmas thank you very much for
sending your question goob think thanks
to you as well
oops here in the chat I'm sure I'll have
other questions uh what Christmas do you
think percent of five can have these
same commercial success today that's
something like Final Fantasy seven did
when it released no absolutely no no it
phase well Zelda may be right like 587
was a game that came along it like it's
struck with the iron was hot like yeah
just at the right time and did something
that no other games are really doing it
had a lot of marketing money put behind
it and sort of broke free of I think the
audience that typically goes for these
games why are you all smiling yeah I
think we'll see persona 5 do well for
sure but I don't think it's going to be
sort of a revolutionary game okay does
it work anybody else contend with that
yeah I think it's to it it's just niche
enough to not um be able to get the same
traction I think okay you want to know
something embarrassing you've never
played phone fancy seven that or any
other Final Fantasy I played two hours
of 15 oh yeah Chris waters had never
played one and we had to review the
third fantasy 13 it was amazing watching
him react to all the things just didn't
make sense to even fans did he liked it
I think he walked away with like a seven
or six okay yeah I forget but uh you
guys should play a Final Fantasy game
oh I want places very badly huh Final
Fantasy thirteen three no Cassidy says
the cat girl's name is Anne Anne and
she's perfect that changes things bland
alright I'm gonna move on if only to get
that graphic off the screen
boy Christmas and thank you much just so
much for a question
and goob as always thank you for your
input and so persona 5 release date it's
going on April 4th every foreign will
hit March 29th from Lucy James and these
caves in the UK uh yeah you can stay
tuned the game spot for that will have
Charlotte videos and our stories about
the game coming out before its release
as in its western release mm-hmm
it's been on Japan since September and
for I've seen Japan likes it yes yeah
cool so for those are you excited for
that that is kind I think that's our
like I don't know I'm like kind of
subjective but I think that's the
biggest next release after yeah yeah a
few would end of April's pretty packed
with like meet with mid-tier yeah yeah
but persona 5 is gonna stand out and
then pray I think will be the next one
that get people gets people talking cool
but yeah hopefully persona 5 is
interesting to a lot of people cool so
yeah say at GameSpot calm as we approach
the release of that game
[Music]